and off the boards trying to get to that one
himself but it'll be brought back up by farby
he'll drop it back here's the shot scores
another early goal by the Flyers as Scott
lton coming down the same Wing but that was the
direct one that one that beat UK pinan right here
nice Puck movement moves to the outside back to
the outside and the man going to the net the shot
from the face off dot you see farby gives that
pass off he drives through to the net he takes
the vision right away from Lucan try to PL up
the boards to The Far Side now it's connecting
him behind the net play it back to the line
wers try to work it in front scores rebound
falling right to the far side and Lou belpedio
picks it up his first goal well belpedio he's
going to get a big rebound here they're winning
battles down low and they're throwing to the
front of the net he's going to collect his
first NHL goal right here on the quick shot
big rebound left right there and it comes right
back to him and he puts it into the back of the
net you see 37 he had half the net to fire that
one in two shots on net so far two goals for the
Flyers yeah delor doing his best to knock the
end wall over there too and he gets going he's
not stopping W's fourth line working it in front
paling with it chance on goal and that one stopped
by Lucan there's a fight trying to get him the B
there they all fall to the ice gravity is a real
thing guys saers play it back to the line here's
do Skinner down the boards with him on the left
side sent towards Harrison he blockers it up and
out of play pass across that one is knocked down
by a stick and the backand pass at the point
keeps it in here fairby sends it in front Luc
and big stop on Forester pared in front and the
puck is cleared taking on Steelers he tries to
stand Thompson up a little bit on that entry
Flyers get it back here's a return pass in
the slot and Lucan read it well and he is there
to make the stop now you see haon just going to
feed this one through to the net right here and
tip it tips it and just tries to get it past up
there Center rice Sabers with his own entry as do
tips it ahead and Rusk down to the corner battling
with elpidio now petka turns it over here's
a breakaway chance for the Flyers one-on-one
Lucan won't make the save this time the Flyers
up three nothing on kkn breakaway goal with 503
left in the opening [Applause] period there's
pressure down here P has got this Puck and he
tries feeding it back but he's carrying the puck
to the D you got to move that quicker he tries to
make the pass it's not a good pass and it's picked
off moved forward and connect the one-on-one with
Lucan and just beats him on the short side when
you're coming out of the offensive zone if you're
going to move the puck to the point he's got some
time for Buffalo Thompson up the middle there's
a rocket of the pass Thompson gets enough of it
now in the far Corner looking for some help and
he's got it in front puts it off the iron left
in this first period here's Brandon byr is going
to get this PO down low nice job coming up from
behind the net finding darene right there the
quick shot right off the pipe and that's as close
as the Sabers have come so far here in this first
period and look how they had the golender moving
that's why I say you got to get some pucks to this
guy not stable in there more pucks you can get
to him here's a quick up Dylan cousins in the
slot dangles to the net and that one Harrison gets
a piece and it goes to the corner Alex tuck with
a shot that's block gets it back again raling
to the corner he will return the favor and sky
that one up near Center Greenway touch pass ah
head seing Tage Thompson who cuts it Thompson
takes the shot and AR with a stop now tuck with
Tage Thompson in the slot that pass is tip by
him kept in by Conor Clifton and here he picks
it up drives to the net pulls a little curl and
drag there he had 10 down out and gone Brink he
had no idea where it was going on he was doing
push-ups in front of the net right there and
just missed back to the line for Steeler his
shot off the end boards Len trying to WRA it in
couple of watchs out it kept out and then Clinton
makes a big stop here at this near post and the
follow up of the play not enough in time and the
Sabers have to regroup and now here's a turnover
loose puck in front Luca and got a piece of that
one and because of that the Flyers are able
to continue to eat time off the the clock
here with a three nothing lead staying in
the Buffalo Zone bar be able to leave it
onto the wing and a backhander down below
the goal [Music] line back door pass they
score delore sends that one across for halfway
and that was a bang bang play at the far post
going to get a second of the Year here the
fire is just just literally throwing this
one deep this is Nick delore throwing it back
down low there's Tage Thompson catching up to
the play now leaves it for Alex tuck his pass
through the legs of Greenway Thompson keeps it
in almost spit a ramit himself into a scoring
chance but he does keep possession Thompson
works it in first shot P tuck with a rebounding
fir him wide an EXC excellent individual effort
here by Tage Thompson just inside the blue line
and he's going to try to make something happen
here all in his own curl and drag get into that
center lane that fires it to the net yeah that
puck lifted High into the Buffalo Zone glove down
quick up again as the Sabers try to stretch the
plate quickly Greenway to The Far Side a out to
challenge the aoso shot makes the stop eight 12
shots here in this period not connecting here's
Kyle aoso with a quick shot Aon gets the glove
up Flyers finishing a change and the Sabers are
doing their same now to find a way through as
the Flyers try to stack it up a little bit but
the SA back Mo up middle stack a stick battle
Far Side Yoki har shoots the scores Savers are
on the board four to one Flyers with the lead
and maybe Buffalo now can keep chipping away
a little bit get his first of the year being
aggressive we talked about the D being aggressive
here in this third period trying to get up in the
offense exactly what you're looking for nice
feed right there and he steps in the quick shot
and he's going to be Arison on the short side
Center Red Line to Thompson for Skinner on the
wing and then three Flyers there comes back to
Skinner for Johnson he drops it the tuck and a
stick handle does not work and farby will send
it through for a partial break and ler won't
stop that shot Brink goes to the net Bobby Brink
makes it 51 Flyers with 832 to go Philadelphia
with pressure to turnover right here power comes
across Brink just comes up through the middle of
the ice he's going to get fed from the wall right
there and he's just one-on-one with Lucan and he
comes in and power just not able to recover
get back there and tries getting the stick
out but he just gets past rusek can't keep it
in and now it's tipped in behind byro trying
to lean that one off the post is tip it one of
a few players to have a one-on-one against the
Sabers net minder UK peka Lucan in here tonight in
the third period of this one the Flyers 51 on the
Sabers yeah referee doing a nice job
separ far is that KBS yeah yeah Krebs
far it's over nothing comment ref's do
a nice job there separating but sabes
ay hey from start of this game they
had a tough time solving the pressure